the news is important because
information is power information is
knowledge
and people
in morovia they want to know what's
happening
but how do they get informed
not everyone have access to internet
people can't afford to buy the newspaper
the job is called the daily talk
i created a chalkboard
from what i saw happening in librarian
society
it all started doing a labyrinth about
on rex
the warring factions were not giving the
librarian public the actual information
it was all just propaganda
i thought it was to have a meeting of
communication established where people
get the actuality of what was happening
i have a staff that i work with
my only challenge is the financial
support we don't have financial support
our daily talk we receive little
donation from people
sorry for the interruption people
calling me telling me what's happening
to other places so sometimes that was
happening
we have realized that there are three
categories of audience for daily talk
the literature the simulators and the
illiterates all of them form part of the
society and want to know what's
happening
we focus our attention on the illiterate
reading audience by using symbols and
pictures it's about critiquing all the
politicians of who they are and what
they want to do i have problems with
past government uh
senator director was created
and even this government
they destroyed the bull three times
at that time there was not much fresh
freedom in libra
they came to me and asked me
why did i have to publish such a story
i managed to have continued some of
these pressures
i love to see people being informed
i see myself not only as an informant
but uneducated who know that his indeed
lord by the last great people i just
love it
you